the Big Bang Theory's kaley cuoco my
girl a lot of people forget that before
she played penny on that show she was
actually John Ritter's daughter on eight
simple rule and you know in the shell
they had a very special relationship
both on and off camera
well this Tuesday will mark the 15th
anniversary of John's tragic passing and
Kaylie is opening up about her final
moments with her TV dad to this day if
anyone asks me John Ritter I I get this
kill because I love him so much on the
day of his death John fell ill on the
set and told the cast and crew he just
needed some rest in the new documentary
John Ritter behind closed doors Kaylie
says he came by her dressing room in the
moment will stay with her forever hey go
hey Michael are you okay heard you're
sick
cuz I'm okay someone talk to you for a
second I was like okay and you sat down
the couch she goes I love you
and I was like I love you too silly man
goes no I want you to know I love you I
said I love you too he goes that's it
and he gave me a hug
and I was the last I saw him John was
bleeding internally from a tear in his
heart vessel and later passed away in a
hospital after mourning his sudden loss
the show would continue with John's
character also passing away ET talked to
a bend 17 year old Kelly and her TV
sister Amy Davidson about doing their
first show without him we always got
together in the back and we we got a
little circle we always sweet John would
look at me all of a sudden we do a
prayer and they look us in the eyes on
Wednesday I love you I love you I love
you I love you every show and for him
not to be back there Friday night
tomorrow night it's gonna be bizarre but
we're gonna send it up to him it's gonna
be the first one we haven't done that
yet this is nice too many he was
America's dad and his passing is still
mourn today we loved John more than
anything and we're not the only people
that have lost someone so close to us
and I know that you know other people
have too
[Music]